[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Hi, my
name is Maya Kaczorowski.
I'm a product manager
in security and privacy
at Google focused on encryption.
Today, we'll be talking
about encryption at rest,
both how Google encrypts data
by default and the options
that we give you to encrypt
data as a developer on GCP.
Google uses several layers of
encryption to protect data.
First, at the
hardware device layer,
we encrypt hard disks
and solid state drives
with a device-level key.
Then we encrypt data at
the storage system layer.
Let's dive a bit
deeper into that.
To understand how storage layer
encryption at Google works,
you need to understand how
Google stores your data.
For example, when you upload
a cat video to Google,
it's broken into subfile
chunks for storage
and distributed across
Google storage systems.
Each chunk of data is encrypted
with an individual encryption
key so that no
two chunks of data
will have the same encryption
key, even if they're
part of the same Google
Cloud Storage object,
owned by the same customer,
or stored on the same machine.
This gives us super low-level
cryptographic isolation
of data.
Access control lists ensure
that each chunk can be decrypted
only by authorized
Google services,
using data encryption keys.
These keys encrypt data chunks
and are stored with the data
chunks themselves.
And of course, we never store
unencrypted keys on disk.
In fact, the data
encryption keys
are themselves encrypted
with another key for storage,
called a key encryption key.
This is commonly referred
to as envelope encryption
because one key is
enveloping another.
The key encryption
keys are stored
centrally in Google's internal
key management service.
Using a central key
management service
makes storing and encrypting
data at Google scale manageable
and allows us to track
and control data access
from a central point.
Data stored in Google
Cloud is encrypted
at the storage level, using
either AES-256 or AES-128.
As a customer, you can use
our default Google encryption
just by using Google Cloud.
We already encrypt your data
stored at rest by default,
without any action required
from you, using one
or more encryption mechanisms.
For additional options, we offer
a cloud key management service
that lets you
generate, use, rotate,
and destroy the encryption
keys that you manage.
You can also bring your
own encryption keys
to the cloud with our
customer-supplied encryption
keys feature.
To learn more, read
our white paper,
"Encryption at rest in
Google Cloud Platform".
[MUSIC PLAYING]